Schwarze löcher scheinen eine viel größere rolle, im universum
Zu spielen als bisher angenommen das ist das ergebnis einer neuen untersuchung von 74 galaxien in unserer. Nähe naja was man
Im kosmos sohn er nennt das absolut frappierende die supermassereichen schwarzen löcher ins zentrum der galaxien sind nicht nur quasi die
resteverwerter und halten mit ihren gravitation die galaxie mit zusammen nein sie steuern auch die entstehung der galaxien
Je nachdem wie groß sie sind
passiert nämlich etwas vollkommen anderes in den sternenhaufen was genau und warum jetzt in kriegs und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Das ist wirklich ziemlich irre galaxien werden quasi von den supermassereichen schwarzen löchern in ihren zentren
gesteuert dass das ergebnis einer studie eines internationalen
forschungsteams schon länger fiel auf dass die größe der schwarzen löcher
Im zentrum von galaxien mit der größe der jeweiligen galaxie in einem
Zusammenhang steht je größer das schwarze loch desto mehr sterne auch in der galaxie und nicht umgekehrt aus irgendeinem
Rätselhafte und gibt es keine umgekehrte beziehung das schwarze loch könnte ja zum beispiel
größer sein und weniger sterne in der galaxie übrig lassen oder es könnte einen zufälligen verteilung geben mal größer mal kleiner und so
Weiter und so fort aber es gibt eine ganz exakte beziehung die wurde jetzt auch
Exakt bestätigt bei den 74 untersuchten galaxien gab es eine ganz klare beziehung zwischen den
Supermassereichen schwarzen löchern in ihrem zentrum und der größe der galaxie um zu diesem ergebnis
zu gelangen untersuchte das team das
lichtspektrum der galaxie und konnte so das alter der sterne und damit die sternen bildung beurteilen und das ergebnis ist absolut klar große
schwarze löcher sind viel effizienter als kleinere in ihrem umfeld entstehen viel mehr sterne viel schneller
sie scheinen nicht nur selbst materie zu verdichten sondern durch ihr
gravitationsfeld auch in ihrer umgebung
Die verdichtung von materie
voranzutreiben und zitat bei den galaxien mit einem massereichen schwarzen loch wurde die sternbilder und früher und schneller
Gestoppt als bei denen mit kleineren 18 löchern so ignazio martin navarro von der university of california
Diese galaxien waren im schnitt 4
achtung vier milliarden jahre früher fertig als galaxie mit kleineren schwarzen löchern sie hatten also viel früher 99 prozent
Ihrer endgültigen masse gebildet als die
galaxien mit kleinen schwarzen löchern aber was passiert hier genau zitat es gibt verschiedene wege durch die ein schwarzes loch energie in die galaxie
freisetzen kann und theoretiker haben verschiedene ideen dazu wie das abstoppen der stern bildung passiert sagt aaron
romanowski von der san jose state university vermutet wird dass es einen ganz besonderen
zusammenhang gibt sobald ein schwarzes loch in eine aktive phase tritt und besonders viel materie ansaugt könnte das die stern bildung
Beeinträchtigen die entstehung von galaxien würde demnach in ganz bestimmten phasen erfolgen die durch das supermassereiche schwarze loch, im zentrum
gesteuert werden das schwarze loch wäre quasi der
Puppenspieler der die galaxie steuert und regelt ich bin ja so gespannt auf das erste bild des
supermassereichen schwarzen loches aus dem zentrum unserer galaxie der milchstraße
Im april wurde sagittarius a stern so heißt es von unzähligen teleskopen synchronisiert aufgenommen und wird gerade am
in boston
zusammengerechnet täglich wird denn das ergebnis kommen
Das wird der absolute wahnsinn wenn er es nicht verpassen wollte dadurch mehr ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit dafür
Draufklicken wie sehen schwarze löcher wirklich aus da geht es genau
Um dieses foto das wir jetzt vielleicht bald hoffentlich sehen können also ansonsten bis dann
bleibt da